hello believe nation I started the
mentor me series with the idea to spend
a little bit more time with people
who've done a lot more than us and
hopefully by watching their videos a
little bit about their mindsets their
beliefs their values their work ethic
the way they think rubs off onto us so
that we can be the best version of
ourselves so today we're going to learn
from Zig Ziglar on motivation mentor
music and as a reminder for you guys as
Zig is talking if he says something
that's really inspirational or
motivating for you make sure to write it
in the comments below and put it with
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired as well I'm not gonna spend
much time on work and don't look shocked
it's not that I don't think it's
tremendously important because it is
we've got to accept responsibility we've
got to accept the fact that we've got to
perform and as I tell the kids all over
America today now is the best time
you'll ever have in life to get ahead
now is the most opportune time in
America that it has ever been to get
ahead here's what I say if you show up
for work on time and stay there until
the appointed departure time if you do
what they pay you to do and then they
pay you then nobody owes anybody
anything now if you want to raise get
there a few minutes early ask for extra
things to do be cheerful and positive
and optimistic and helpful don't goof
off and try to get out of work
deliberately seek the boss to find extra
work and then I will absolutely
guarantee you a raise in short order now
your current employer might not be the
one to give you the raise but somebody
down the streets gonna see what you're
doing and they're gonna say if that's
the boy I want working for me that's the
girl I want working for me because he or
she are doing more than they're paid to
do that's the way you get a raise oh
don't misunderstand you got to work you
you can't be like this old boy down home
and you're gonna find out earlier than
an awful lot of old boys down home
somebody at least they're worth when I
was down there somebody asked him how
long you've been working for his
continent he said ever since they
threatened to fire me so that's about
the size of it yeah but here's what
we've discovered if you got a good
self-image if you have your goals set in
life if you've got the right mental
attitude nobody has to tell you go to
work that just follows naturally so this
is what we're going to work on and you
got to have a desire to succeed
you can't just casually want the good
things in life it's got to become a
passion for you your dream has got to be
more than just an idle thoughts you got
to be willing to build a foundation
under it and that's for sure we're going
to be taking these steps and quite
obviously ladies and gentleman I believe
that these steps are what is necessary
but let me let me identify to you what
one of the major problems in America is
one of the problems as you see we have
said to people all of these things are
available we've shown in the big homes
the big cars the swimming pools the jet
set the you know that style of living
that a lot of people say yeah I'd kind
of like that then on the other side of
the ledger we have said everybody not
only can get these things but everybody
deserves these things America is a rich
and affluent land and everybody can get
them then we have another segment of
society that says that crime is caused
by poverty with one segment saying you
deserve these things and you ought to
have them and another segment saying
that crime is caused by poverty we
subliminally subconsciously plan a
thought don't wait to get it go get it
right now there has never been a
definitive study that establishes any
correlation between crime and poverty
during the Great Depression the crime
rate was much lower in 1939 than it was
in 1930 at the end of a decade of the
roughest depression our country has
overhead so what we're saying is let's
start climbing some steps you see we
could draw you an elevator to the top
but I'd have to be honest and say the
elevator doesn't work you're gonna have
to start taking these steps and you're
going to have to take them one at a time
but I've discovered that people don't
mind taking the steps if you tell them
where they are
show them how many there are and then
tell them exactly how to climb the steps
but you see you gotta climb the steps
you can't skip them on September the
15th 1944 in Jackson Mississippi at the
YWCA at exactly 18 minutes after 8
o'clock I saw the participant over by
the Nickelodeon now some of you won't
know what a Nickelodeon is that's a
jukebox ok and I thought to myself boy
what I'd really like to do is I'd like
to go over there and I'd like to grab
her in my arms and I'd like to start
hugging her and kissing her right now
that's exactly what I wanted to do but
if I had she wouldn't be sitting here is
my wife of over 30 years today because I
would have skipped too many steps
so I did something real original I
walked up to her and I said and she said
hi and the first thing you know since it
was a dance that we were little YWCA
dancing we were dancing and I got a
telephone number that night we had a lot
of telephone calls and and then one day
I said hey we ought to be going out and
she said okay so we had a date then we
had an oven in another one and then you
know it wasn't but two years and two
months and 11 days and one hour later
that she became my very own but we took
some steps along the way I don't care a
bright you are in school you cannot move
from 2 times 2 equals 4 into analytical
geometry you got to take some steps now
the mistake a lot of people make is they
get on one step and sit there you know
that's not what I'm talking about either
what I'm talking about is taking these
steps and then you will get these number
of years ago Laura majors my executive
assistant got a phone call from a lady
in Birmingham Alabama and then of the
conversation she said Zig she said I
believe this woman thinks she's got an
impossible problem but I believe you can
solve that problem her with her in just
a few minutes if you will spend that
time with her I said well Lori tell her
to meet me backstage I'll get there
about 10 minutes early they my schedule
was such that was about all I had well I
got there and I was on the backstage
behind the curtain on one side she
spotted me from the other side and if
she walked across the stage I have never
seen as much anger in a human being in
my life as I saw in her she almost
started crying when she saw me see that
oh I'm just so glad to see you I got
this horrible job I hate it I hate
everything about it I hate everybody
I mean you talking about negative nails
she was it she said can you help me now
understand I've only got about ten
minutes so I looked at her and one thing
I have learned I don't do counseling but
I talk with a lot of people who do in
psychologist psychiatry and the ministry
and they tell me that everybody who
comes to you with a problem are not
necessarily looking for a solution I
couldn't understand that for a long time
why do they bring your problem if they
don't want to solve it well I can tell
you why they want to tell you about it
you about it you better you about it you
about and if you foul up the deal then
solve the problem they can tell you
again you again they want the attention
that goes with the problem and every
company just about it has that kind of
an individual they want the attention
that goes with griping and and
complaining well I looked at the lady
and it wasn't unkindly but firmly I said
there yes and you know ma'am I'm afraid
your problem it's about to get worse she
said what do you mean I said I believe
they gonna fire you
[Music]
she was stunned I couldn't have done it
more if I'd hit her in the face with a
bucket of ice water
she said fire me why on earth would they
fire me inflation and her voice clearly
said they're the bad guys
I'm the good guy why don't they fire
them and keep me have you ever noticed
that people who are the problem never
recognize that they are they're in
complete denial they think denial is
just a river in Egypt why would they
fire me I said ma'am I don't believe
there's a company in America big enough
to contain this much poison in one small
spot have you ever noticed that when
somebody is about to lose something
they've been complaining about whether
it's a car a home a mate a job or
whatever when all of a sudden it appears
they're gonna lose them it takes on
brand-new value she looked at me and
said well what can I do I said do you
really want to know she said yes I do
that's the reason I came to see you I
came looking for help but you sure
haven't been any help so far
I said well ma'am I've got an idea and I
will absolutely guarantee you it
positively definitely absolutely will
work if you will just do it she said
I'll try anything within reason I said
okay when you get home tonight
all of your household tasks are complete
it's bedtime get off in a room right by
yourself get a sheet of paper out and at
the top of it right I like my job
because he interrupted me she said
that'll be easy I don't like nothing
about that job don't like nothing about
those people down there and I said well
just as a matter of curiosity do you
work there for benevolent reasons or do
they pay you for working there she said
well I got a confess they pay me and I
said you don't like to be paid oh she
said yes I do
I said okay tell you what you do open
your notebook right now we'll start our
list of the things you like about your
dog they pay you for working there and
you do like it don't you said absolutely
but she just stood there I said no open
your notebook now and we'll get busy on
the list he just stood there I said man
let me let me tell you what my
experience in life has been I've
discovered that in 100% of the cases no
exceptions people who won't take step
number one never take step number two
you see she had come to me with an
impossible dream her dream was that nice
mr. Ziegler was going to solve all of
her problems and she would live happily
ever after but folks I Got News for you
I can't solve her problems I can't solve
your problems but I will give you some
steps that are absolutely definitely and
positively will work for you as it
worked
eventually for her I said well ma'am let
me tell you something unless you're
willing to take step number one right
now it's been nice talking with you she
angrily opened her notebook before we
got through there were 22 things she
liked about her job
now I'm gonna that not only did they pay
her for working there that they paid her
above average
she had three weeks vacation was paid
she had a retirement program she was in
on profit-sharing
she had health insurance life insurance
and accident insurance
she lived less than ten minutes from
home she was in no management decisions
that company senator three seminars a
year to be paid for she had her own
private office and party played 22
things that she liked about her job now
I said man when you get home tonight
everything is finished get off in a room
right by yourself
close the doors change one word from I
like my job to I love my job get in
front of that mirror and folks I cannot
say this strongly enough but I'm going
to try the eyes are the windows of the
soul look yourself in that and with
excitement and enthusiasm say I love my
job because they pay me for working
there I love my job because they pay me
above average were working there I love
my job because they have a wonderful
insurance program I love my job before
every one of the statements you will
sleep better that night you see there's
something hidden in what I'm saying to
you now when she says I like my jobs is
really saying I'm grateful for my job
and of all of the emotions we can have
according to hands sell you the number
one stress pessimist in America
the healthiest of all human emotions is
gratitude I said you go down that list I
like my job I love my job rather that is
a way of gratitude you'll sleep better
the first night tomorrow morning when
you get up get back in front of the
mirror just before you go to work get
back in front of the mirror and repeat
the process again with excitement and
enthusiasm I love my job because and
take the list with you because the
reality is you see you will have started
to change from a fault finder to a good
finder some people do really find fault
like there's a reward for it they really
do take the list with you and you will
be able to add to that list absolutely
guaranteed do this every morning and
every night and you will have an
astonishing recovery from this advanced
case of stinking thinking now I didn't
say that to her but I'm saying it to you
that's what it was it was an advanced
case of stinking thinking well six weeks
later I was back in Birmingham Alabama I
was doing a follow up sales seminar now
the lady was not in sales but she had
been listening to my tapes he had been
listening to Automobile University and
she had discovered that everybody sells
everybody will ever hear this is in
selling whether you're a school teacher
a civil service worker military
personnel an executive secretary doesn't
make any difference what you do you sell
every day of your life there she was on
there at the sales seminar seated on the
front row grinning as to why she could
have eaten a banana sideways I'm telling
you you're talking about somebody that
was excited she was turned on I said
well how you done man she granted even
more broadly and said mr. Ziegler I'm
doing wonderfully well and thank you for
asking
she said you cannot believe how much
those people down there have changed
I got a lid on the line folks you're not
gonna change anybody else did you change
you everything really does begin with
you now you see the unfortunate thing
this lady had been raised in a very
negative environment first her parents
had told her that should never amount to
anything they said you know you're
always late you're always sloppy why
can't you be like your brother or your
sister or whatever when she got married
her husband had continued it and so
herself talk had become completely
negative
everything is he said about herself was
negative out you know like dad said I'll
never mind anything like my husband says
I can't do anything right but when she
started changing the input then some
radical changes took clothes I want to
talk a little bit about goes on the line
of how do you lose 37 pounds and write a
book I'm just going to kind of give you
that as an example for 24 years of my
adult life by choice I weighed well over
200 pounds I say by choice because you
see I have never accidentally eaten
anything
I mean it's always been deliberate and
when I choose to eat too much today I
have chosen to weigh too much
tomorrow you can choose to set goals and
realize your potential or you can choose
not to set them now if you choose not to
set them you got to understand that the
consequences are not going to be good
down the road for 24 years I was going
to lose that way as a matter of fact in
24 years I lost several thousand pounds
of weight how many of you already know
exactly what I'm talking about but he
was it until I wrote it down put a date
on it list of the obstacles I had to
overcome identified the people the
groups organizations I needed to work
with spelled out a plan of action set
that time limit in there and identified
all of the benefits to me it was only
when I did that that the goal became a
reality and I lost the weight for 10 or
15 years I was going to write a book you
know anybody who's going to do just a
whole lot of things folks I was going to
write a book but it wasn't until I got
busy writing the book and writing the
plans first before the book ever
materialized now if it sound like I'm
trying to sell you on heaven goals how
many of you are getting close already
how many of you being coming convinced
right quick like let's you need to have
those go there's no question about it
the immortal JCPenney many many years
ago said give me a stock clerk with a
goal and I'll give you a man will make
history but give me a man without a goal
and I'll give you a stock clerk now the
interesting thing is Gold's do not care
who has them let me give you a classic
example of the way they work in 1950 a
war-torn devastated Japan a nation who
had lost an incredibly high percentage
of its young men their cities were in
ruins they'd been
but in 1950 they got together they
meaning industry and government got
together and said ago the goal was we're
going to be the number one nation in the
world during the 1950s in the production
of textiles in 1959 ladies and gentlemen
they accomplished that objective in 1960
they said another gold we're going to be
the number one nation in the world in
the production of steel now when you
understand there's no iron ore in Japan
of any significance there's no coal of
any significance there we're gonna be
the number one nation in the world in
the production of steel it seemed like
an absurd goal and yet they reached
their objectives they've taken all of
the steps in 1970 the Japanese said
another goal they said you're in the
seven is will be the number one nation
in the world in the production of
automobiles they missed it folks one
year it took them until 1980 in 1980
they set another goal and this time
their goal was we're going to be the
number one nation in the world of the
production of computers and electronics
yes indeed ladies and gentlemen you
absolutely must have those goals you got
to write them down you got to put a date
on it you got to identify those
obstacles you've got to identify the
people the groups you need to work with
you got to find out what it is you need
to know you got to develop a plan of
action and you got to write it down
what's in it for me now that's a formula
that I have just given you pure and
simple now if I were to ask you what
three times three was very is that a
person here who could not instantly
answer it but if I were to ask you what
is 5,000 128 times 2165 odds are
enormous but very few of you could pop
out the answer that quickly buddy if I
were to say to you get your pencil and
paper out figure it out then all of you
could figure it out why you know the
formula you see if you know the formula
it really doesn't make any difference
ladies and gentlemen what the goal
really is when I started to write the
book I took precisely the same steps
that I'm talking about
wrote down the objective I wrote down
the time I completed or expected to
complete the book identify the obstacles
there and yes I know this is repetitious
it's the mother of learning I wrote out
and identified the people the groups
organizations I needed to work with I
devised a plan of action to do it I
spelled out what I needed to know and I
wrote it all down what's in it for me
you see the basic problem is most people
when they're working on their job they
get to thinking you know I really ought
to be spending time at home with my
family and then when at home with a
family get to thinking you really ought
to be out there working for my family
and so in that they're working for their
family their mind is back home and when
they're back home their mind is back out
there in the field and then they tell
everybody well I don't ever have time to
do anything no wonder you're always
traveling you see the basic problem is
not lack of time it is lack of direction
we all have exactly the same amount of
time whether we're a millionaire or a
pauper all of us have 24 hours every
single day the truth is ladies and
gentlemen we must have goals if we're
gonna do anything goes do a lot of
things for example they enable you to
chase the blues away I've never known
anybody who was truly depressed who had
specific and long-range goals and what
goals do is they create activity and you
see activity as you work towards
reaching them creates the very
excitement which you need in order to
accomplish our reach your objectives the
psychologists put it this way logic will
not change and emotion but action will
and as you get busy working towards of
these dreams of yours and yes you
absolutely must have your dreams ladies
and gentlemen and what we're gonna do is
look at the ways you build a foundation
underneath those dreams several years
ago they did an experiment with a number
of college students and in this
particular experiment they let them go
to sleep and they hook these brain
machines up to them with these brain
machines they could
precisely within a matter of seconds in
the student went to sleep then they
could tell when that student started to
dream and as the student would start to
dream they would awaken him or her and
then they'd let him go back to sleep and
that is no problem but when they started
a dream they would awaken them again and
with those brainwave machines they can
tell exactly when they start to dream at
the end of one night of this kind of
treatment many of the students were
nervous and fidgety at the end of two
nights of this kind of treatment where
they had a reasonable amount of sleep
but no dreaming they became very
irritable and very short in very cross
at the end of just three nights of a
reasonable amount of sleep but no
dreaming they could tell that some of
them were headed for some psychological
difficulties and so what they did was
they aborted the experiment now about 24
hours later most of the students were
back to normal within a week all of them
had returned 100% but the experiment
proves something very conclusively and
that's this when you're asleep ladies
and gentlemen you need your dreams I'm
here to tell you that when you're wide
awake you also need your dreams you must
have your goals you'll never make it as
a wandering generality you must become a
meaningful specific if you're going to
work tomorrow because that's what you
did yesterday you're not going to be as
good tomorrow as you are yesterday
because now you're two days older and no
closer to the gold which you do not have
you can't make it as a wandering
generality most people understand you
got to become a meaningful specific it
reminds me of an experiment done some
little while ago by John Henry Fabray
the great French naturalist he took a
number of processionary caterpillars so
named because they follow each other in
a procession and he land them around a
flower pot until they formed a
never-ending circle and they started
going round and round 24 hours that
first day and then they went the next
day and the next and by the
the third of the fourth day he put some
pine needles into the center of that
flower pot that's the food of the
processionary caterpillar they kept
going round and round seven full days
and seven full nights but they went
round and round until they literally
drop dead from starvation and exhaustion
with an abundance of food less than six
inches away they had starved to death
because they confused activity with
accomplishment you've got some friends
that are in the same shape they're busy
busy bee all the time they're going
going going going and they're here and
they're there and they're somewhere else
but they never really accomplished
anything because they don't have those
specific clearly identifiable objectives
you've gotta have those goals and this
story really covers all of the concepts
all of the ideas in which we believe
that's the reason we're going to give
you this story in the detail which we
are
when I met Bernie you know we had a
little discussion about what he was
doing in Kansas City and he said I came
down here the surgeon and I said here
but he cost a lot of money to come this
far he laughed he said with zigge thanks
to my son David I don't have to worry
about money I said Bernie that sounds
like a story why don't you tell me he
said I'll be glad to this is the story
he said you know think when our son
David was born I joy
literally knew no bounds we already had
our two daughters now we had our son and
that was what we had hoped that we would
have when we got married but he said it
wasn't long before we noticed that
something was wrong with David his
little head hung to limply to the right
side of his body for it to be a normal
situation and he drew too much and so we
went to the doctor and the family doctor
said no problem he'll outgrow it but he
says you know sig we knew that it wasn't
quite that simple so we took him to a
specialist and the specialist after a
very thorough examination told us that
he had the reverse of clubs fee and he
said we treated him for that for several
weeks and then it dawned on us that this
wasn't it it was more serious than there
so we found who the top specialist was
in all of Canada and we went to him and
this space
after a very thorough examination said
to us that David is a [ __ ] yes
cerebral palsy he's never going to be
able to walk or talk or count to ten and
I suggest that you put him in an
institution for his own good and for the
good of the quote normal members of the
family but Bernie laughs he looked at me
and he said you know Ziggy I'm not a bar
I'm a cellar I could not by the idea
that my son was going to grow up and be
a vegetable all that doctor had really
convinced me to do was to go find a
doctor who was not problem conscious and
looked for one who was solution
conscious so we went to other Dottie's
that as a matter of fact we went to 30
different doctors and all 30 of them in
essence said of the same thing and that
is that there is no hope for this little
boy and then they heard of a dr.
Pearlstein down in Chicago reputedly the
foremost authority in the world but he
was so good that he was booked for two
solid years in advance now that didn't
particularly bother Bernie because hope
for the first time had reared its
elusive head and Bernie just figured
that somehow another he was going to get
his son in front of dr. Pearlstein well
he found out that dr. Pearlstein was a
bridge player found out his home number
found out that he played every Friday
night with his son he called him there
and they made a deal at the first
cancellation that they had dr.
Pearlstein was going to call Bernie and
they would put David or take him on an
airplane Amelia to Chicago well just 11
days later they got the call they loaded
David on the airplane they took him down
there and dr. Pearlstein gave him either
of the most thorough examination I
believe that any child has ever had when
the examination was all over he said to
Bernie this boy is a [ __ ] he has
cerebral palsy he will never be able to
walk or to talk or count to ten if you
listen to the prophets of doom but he
said I want you to know that I am NOT
problem conscious I want you to know
that I am
solution conscious and I firmly believe
there is something which can be done for
David if you are willing to do your part
well rather obviously the live stick
said doctor what is it you wanted to do
spell it out dr. Pearlstein and his
nurses spelled it out in my new detail
he said first of all you're gonna have
to work this little boy beyond all human
endurance then you're gonna have to work
him some more you don't have to push him
until he literally falls and then you
are going to have to push him some more
you've got to understand now that once
you start this process that there is no
backing up or slowing down or staying
away from it this is a lifetime process
because if you ever discontinue this
then he will revert back to where he was
before one last thing don't let him see
any other victims of cerebral palsy
taking therapy because if he watches
them take therapy he will pick up the
awkward inadvertent movements they make
and subconsciously he will make them a
part of his own movements Bernie and
Elaine left Chicago enormous ly excited
because dr. Pearlstein had given them
extra hope he had added believability to
it he had presented them with a plan to
tell you the truth that's what we've
attempted to do all the way through born
to win every time we make your promise
we'll give you a plan of action you see
folks motivation without instruction and
education is ultimately frustrating for
me to tell you you can do something and
not to tell you how is a cruel hoax that
we have studiously avoided throughout
every time we've said you can do it
we've always said here's the way to do
it well they went back to Winnipeg and
they went to work with David they built
a little gymnasium down in the basement
of their home they hired a physical
therapist and a body builder and they
went to work it took him a lot of months
but finally one day David Lyfe cheek
could move the length of his own body it
took him several years but then one day
Bernie got a call from the therapist he
said come on home I believe David is
ready and he raced home and David was
the gymnasium on a mat and as he was
attempting to do a push-up
and as that little body it started to
rise into the air the physical and
emotional exertion was so great there
was that a dry inch of skin on that
little body and the mat appeared as if
somebody had sprinkled it with water
when that one perfect push-up was
completed David and Bernie and Elaine
and the therapist and the bodybuilder
and the two sisters and the neighbors
all broke down and said those tears
which clearly say that happiness is not
pleasure happiness is victory no you
don't pay the price you enjoy the
benefits that Diane was so beautifully
singing about now the story is even more
remarkable when you understand that one
of America's leading universities had
also examined David and they said there
are no motor connections to the right
hand side of his body he has no sense of
balance he will never be able to swim or
to skate or to ride a bicycle he just
simply will be different it probably
take him two years even to learn how to
float on October the 23rd 1971 my wife
and I flew to Winnipeg Canada to attend
the bar mitzvah of quote
little David live suit oh I wish the
television cameras had been turned on
then
I wish the movie cameras of the world
had been there to have witnessed what we
saw a specialist since I've been working
with Bernie a couple of times each year
between of that first day back in 1965
and I had watch David as he grew and as
he made all of that progress but this
particular day as this boy walked tall
and straight and strong to the front of
the synagogue as he uttered those words
that moved him into the manhood of the
faith of his forefathers knowing what I
knew at that particular time that he had
already done as many as eleven hundred
push-ups in a single day that he had
runs six miles non-stop that he was
shooting golf in the high
eight is that he was one of the best
table tennis players in all of Winnipeg
Canada that he was skating on the
neighborhood hockey team that he was
running the wheels off his fourth
bicycle oh I tell the story about David
in a lot of the details because you see
I happen to believe that this story
literally covers all of the areas that
we cover in born to win you see to begin
with they dealt with David on a very
honest basis they never said it's going
to be easy the parents were never told
it's going to be easy they were told
that you've got to stay with it but if
you'll suck it up and tough it out and
stay where that their results are going
to be dramatic they dealt with a thin
character because you see character is
the ability to carry out a good
resolution long after the excitement of
the moment has passed and there were
many times when the excitement was no
longer there but David stayed with it as
did his parents integrity they dealt
integrity of course means basic
wholeness and they dealt with the entire
person of David logic physical mental
and spiritual the whole bit as far as
loyalists concerned nobody I mean those
two big sisters and the mother and the
dad and the doctors and the therapists
they all were loyal to an incredible
degree as they worked with David helping
him to accomplish his objectives and
rather obviously Trust is deeply
involved there because it takes a lot of
trust for a youngster year after year
after year to be willing to do these
things when his buddies are all out
playing and having a marvelous time now
you talk about love when I think of the
story of David Lyfe stick I think it's
one of the most beautiful love stories I
have ever heard
you see when he was about 2 years old
every night they had to put heavy leg
braces on his legs now David is a
beautiful boy Halle of complexion
beautiful green eyes cold black hair and
every night as he would lay there
getting ready to go to bed he would ask
his mom and ask his dad mom do we have
to put the bracelets on the night or dad
do we have to put them on so tight and
you parents obviously will relate to
this here
lizz whom you love deeply and with tears
in his eyes he's asking do you have to
do it but Bernie and Alain life seek
love David so much that they said no to
the tears of the moment so they could
say yes to the laughter of a lifetime
when you love someone you do what is
best for that person let me share with
you a true story out of my notebook of
life number of years ago got an
incredible letter from a gentleman in
Toronto with a substantial cheque in it
he said my friend Steve Walker is
following the wrong road model life he's
working himself to death his family's
falling apart
he's his health is in danger and he's
model himself out of his bowls and he
trusts you and respects you if you will
give us one hour I will fly him to
Dallas and give you this cheque when you
love to have a friend like then I sent
the cheque back and I said come on down
Steve and I had quite a little talk and
in our talk I asked him why he had such
a role model of why did what about this
man that made him so completely
important in his life and he said well
he's the most successful man I have ever
known
and I said well Steve what do you call
success now it took several minutes for
him to go down the list but the
interesting thing is though they're not
in the same order that I have put them
where they list them now these are the
eight things that he said he rarely
considered to be successful if a man was
happy and healthy and at least
reasonably prosperous and secure if he
had friends and peace of mind and good
family relationship and the hope that
future is going to be better he said I
consider that man is successful now I'm
gonna really encourage you to take some
notes right here and all I want you to
do and you'll be the only one who'll see
it somewhere right in
as I go down the list right whether you
get a plus on that one or a minus on
that one you'll be the only one to see
it but it might be an eye-opener you see
most people never dare to evaluate
really where they are and you know where
you are before you can really determine
your chances of getting what you really
want out of life and so I said to Steve
I said I understand but your boss is
very important to you you're considered
to be successful when he finally got
through with the identification as I
said earlier these were the eight things
that he said I think that's important
for success to measure success
I said well Steve let me ask you now as
far as Happy's concerned
tell me how HAP is your Bose is it oh I
don't think he's happy at all
I said why not he said well I've never
heard him laugh and he seldom smiles and
besides that he's got ulcers I said well
don't give a plus or a minus he said all
you give my - please grade yourself as
we go this is so important for you then
I said that also tells me something
about his health if he's got those
ulcers do I give him a plus or minus he
said you give my - I said that also says
something Steve about his peace of mind
because you don't get ulcers because of
what you eat but what's eating you I
said that would give him a plus or minus
he said we give my - I said Steve I've
asked you one question about what
success is what balance is what's
important to you one question and your
boss comes up with three minuses I said
tell me how prospers he is he said man
he's got money running out of his ears
and he's getting more every day
I said we give him a plus on that one
don't wait he said we sure do I said how
secure is your boss he said well he's as
secure as money can make you and I said
well Steve let me ask you did you read
where two billionaire brothers here in
Dallas went bankrupt I said how does
your boss come back we don't have that
kind of money did you read where our
race governor was worth a hundred
million dollars at one point he's now
back
how does your boss compare I don't have
that kind of money now understand Steve
equated security with corporate position
and bucks in the bank so I said well
Steve let me ask you would we give your
boss a plus or minus or dislike question
mark on that he said let's be generous
and give him a question mark I said how
many friends does your boss have I hope
you're marking these for you how many
friends real friends do you does your
boss have he said I don't think he's got
any I'm not his friend I just haven't
had my league I tell you the truth he's
somewhat of a jerk I said okay we give
him a minus on that one I said tell me
about his family and he said well his
wife's divorcing him well that one's
easy to answer I said how much hope does
he have for the future
he said well four I started talking to
you I thought he had a lot but right now
don't think he's got any why did that
statement come forth because for the
first time he had evaluated it that's
what we need to evaluate where we are
are we investing that time properly
using our resources properly what will
the end results be well then I said to
us Steve when that was over we give him
the minus there I said Steve of the
eight things that you consider marks of
success he gets one two three four five
six - --is he gets one plus and one
question mark I asked Steve a question
I'm going to ask you the same question
Steve would you swap places with your
boss right now knowing what you know he
looks at me kind of stunned he slowly
rose to his feet and said no I wouldn't
would you
well I'm one of these real fortunate
people I was raised in Yazoo City
Mississippi now I know a lot of people
go around the country bragging about
being a zoo city but I really am as you
probably know it's not a big place we
don't even have a village drunk we share
with a little community next to us
Main Street runs through the carwash so
we got a mirror
on the end of town make the town look
bigger I mean you know it's not a real
big place but let me tell you why I can
tease about Yazoo City former president
American Medical Association's from
their former president American Bar
Association is from their former pair of
the Southern Baptist Convention is from
their former vice president Southern
Baptist Convention is from their former
chairman of the Republican National
Committee is from their jerrick Lauer's
is from their I mean you know it's quite
a place now a lot of people ask me well
you know how do you account for all of
that well two things had good preachers
and a wonderful Superintendent of
Education that saw to it that the kids
got a good education I'm proud to be
from years uu city we live next door
when I was a child we live next door to
some there's some rich folks now I know
they were raised for two basic reasons
number one that had to cook number two
the cook had something to cook now
during the Depression folks that was a
sure sign of wealth I was over there for
lunch one day as I tried to be every day
and don't misunderstand this now even
though there was a depression on we had
plenty to eat at my house I know we did
because if I ever place pays my plate
for psychic said I always say you know
you've had plenty so I know we had
plenty that particular day the cook
brought the biscuits out and I looked at
him and they were not as thick as my
wristwatch and I said Maude what on
earth happened and he read back and gave
that big old tummy laugh you know and
and she said well let me tell you about
those biscuits she said they squatted to
rise but they just got cooked in the
squat you know anybody gets cooked in
the spot oh there I have a mind to do
there so they're gonna do that but they
have a minders and the gonna doors are
the never dudes you've talked to him you
know they they hear about a good idea
you know and they you hear about it and
try to get them involved and say well
you know I'd love to get involved in it
but it's almost time for the kids to get
out of school and you know this is our
busiest time of the year but I'm really
interested after who gets out I won't
have so many things to do with all the
parties at all and then
get involved in when school ends you
know what happens they say well you know
I didn't realize it but it seems that
we've got more to do than ever before
and you know I'm busier than every day
you gotta take the kids somewhere all
the time when the kids get back in
school and then I'll I'll really get
involved kids get back in school miss
their well you know this is the first
year in 19 years that dear old Central
High has finally fielded a winning
football team and I got to support the
kids there wait a football seniors over
there man I'll really get involved in
football see then they said well you
know it's here nears nearly Thanksgiving
and Christmas and you know people don't
want to be bothered with sort of thing
this time of year wait after the first
of the year man and then I'll really get
outdoor now wait wait wait wait we don't
know exactly what you're thinking you're
thinking I've lost interest but that's
not the way I am let me tell you the way
I am see what I do is I get everything
organized in a real one to three basis
and then when the time comes to strike
man alive I'll pass all these kids that
have gotten out in front of me now but
I'm telling you this is just not the
right time of the year wait after the
first of the year the first leader comes
and they say did did you ever see
weather like this before in your life
I mean you never know whether you live
in San Francisco are buffalo or Yazoo
City whoever it is you live did you ever
see what I like the weather like this I
mean you can't depend on weightless
weather clears up man and then we'll
really get busy the weather clears up
they say you know I haven't hit a golf
ball or weather hook yeah I don't know
when yeah felt like a twerk all the time
you said it yourself you got to have
some time for yourself
will I have a little recreation and then
man alive I'll get with it and they have
another recreation and then they say
well you know it's almost time for the
kids to get out of school that's where
we came in most let me taste some people
who wait for a Matilda to move out or
John to get on the day shift people will
wait for the next senator to be elected
or the next governor to come in people
who wait for the next advertising
program to get started or wait for the
tax structure to change are wait for
anything that happens out there before
they do anything in year other people
who get cooked
in the squad the message is we need to
do it now you don't have to be great to
start as my friend Joe sever says but
you got to start to be great I want to
talk with you about the greatest
profession on the face of this earth I
want to talk to you about the sales
profession I believe I'll go ahead I got
time
I just happen to believe that America is
the greatest land on this earth because
we are a land of salespeople we're
certainly not the greatest because we're
the biggest because we're not Russia and
China and Canada Brazil they're all
bigger than we are
we're not the greatest because we have
the most people why Indian Russia and
China got lots more people than we have
we're not even the biggest because we
have the most are the greatest because
we have the most natural resources
though we've certainly been a bundle it
blessed in that area but then so has
India for that matter much of Africa
parts of Russia Canada Brazil all rich
in natural resources no we're not the
greatest because we have the most people
or the most land but we're the greatest
because essentially we are a land of
sales people and I don't know how you
feel about it but I for one am
tremendously excited about being a sales
person the truth of the matter is
America was discovered by a Salesman
not by any stretch of imagination could
you accuse Christopher Columbus of being
a navigator now if you remember folks
that dude is looking for India now he
missed it 12,000 miles not by any
stretch of imagination could you accuse
him of being a navigator kids you and
you might say well yeah but was he a
Salesman well let me tell you the story
he was an Italian in Spain now that's
way out of his territory he's only got
one prospect to call on and he misses a
sale he swims home now you tell me was
he a Salesman or not he called on
Isabella told her the story
she says Chris it sound like a good idea
but man $12,000 for five little old
ships see a lot of people don't realize
they started out with five but two of
them didn't go over the side and you
might as well know now tell folks I'm
like a cross-eyed discus thrower I don't
set any records but and do keep the
crowd alert and you know and I think
that's imported he told his Abela the
story you know and she related to it she
said you know it sounds wonderful Chris
and if I could raise the $12,000 I've
you know I'd buy the idea too many but
we don't have any money how many of you
sales people have ever had a prospect
tell you whether they'd buy if they had
the money but they just don't have the
money well Chris looked at and he said
look Izzy now understand I was not there
so I'm not certain this is verbatim but
you you got that string of beads hanging
around your neck that let's take him out
of the pawn shop we'll hock them will
finance this deal well your history
books will clearly tell you they use
some unusual methods to raise the money
to finance the trip then when they
started sailing in those three little
ships Columbus really had a sales job
because those sailors thought they were
going to go over the side I mean
literally and every single day he had to
sell in order to say ole and as a matter
of fact he had agreed to turn back
towards the homeland if they had not
discovered our sighted land with
a certain time in just eight hours
before the crucial decision was made is
when they discovered the land the call
came forth land ho and the most
profitable sales call in history came to
a close and then Columbus made the
mistake that a lot of salespeople are
make in our world today he did not
service the account he did not keep on
selling and a man named America's
America's best Pearce's entered the
picture and he serviced the account we
did not become the United States of
Columbus we became the United States of
America America was populated by a
salesman Sir Walter Raleigh toured the
coffee houses of London selling those
ignorant fearful superstitious people on
the idea that they should leave the
relative security of their homeland and
come into this vast uncharted foreboding
a weird wilderness that lay beyond the
sea it was a tremendous sales job we
were freed by a Salesman do you really
understand the tremendous recruiting job
that George Washington had to do he had
to convince the farmers the merchants
the backwoodsmen the shipbuilders the
landowners and all of the people to
leave their homes go to war against the
most powerful nation on the face of this
earth largest army most powerful Navy
and he had to be honest and saying that
look if we win this war there's no way
I'm gonna be able to pay you and if we
lose they're gonna hang you to the
highest tree now how many of you sales
folks do any recruiting kind of see your
hands please now I want you to visualize
this scene you're trying to recruit
somebody to sail with your company and
you have to tell them look if you make
the sale I don't have any money I'm not
gonna be able to pay you but if you miss
the sale we're gonna line you up at
daylight and we're gonna fire
now that was the job Washington had to
do but he did the job you know we won
our independence as soon as we won our
independence Alexander Hamilton the
first Secretary of the Interior or the
treasurer rather came to mr. Washington
who said let's get the Congress to
appropriate some money so that we might
study the methods the British have used
to establish their agents and factories
around the world the money was
appropriated I don't know if you've ever
thought about this not but as you
realize ladies and gentlemen for the
first one hundred and sixty eight years
that America was populated we had only
moved to the Appalachian Mountains did
you realize that with the appropriation
of this money we did set up trading post
and just 30 years later we were already
to the Pacific Ocean
yes I'm proud to sell because you see
our land has been developed because we
are a land of sales people now at this
point you might have a question in your
own mind Woolsey if that's the case if
we as salespeople have done so much why
is it that salespeople are held in such
low esteem why is our reputation not
better why is it that people do not
respect their profession you know more
than they do today well I believe laters
an element that one of the reasons that
only 2% of the graduating seniors from
college today are interested in going in
the profession of selling it is because
we have not done a thorough job as
salespeople basically there are four
reasons why this profession of selling
is not regarded as high as it ought to
be and is fast becoming a hasten at
number one did you realize what the
dictionary says about the word sell the
dictionary says it's a fraud it's a hoax
it's right there in the dictionary can
you believe such a thing like that we
ought to sue those Rascals for writing
such things is that
number two we've done allows a job of
selling the profession of selling
now we've sold our goods we've sold our
products we've sold our services but we
really haven't done a very good job of
letting people know what the sales
profession is all about but we're
correcting that right now and you're
part of the correction because by the
time we get through here you're gonna
have that jumping up and down enthusiasm
about the profession of selling see a
lot of people are tremendously proud of
their company awfully proud of their
products their goods or their services
but for whatever reason they seem to be
a little hesitant to let people know
they're in the profession of selling we
just simply have not done the sales job
now there's the third reason why a lot
of people don't really understand what
the profession of selling is all about
and why they have so many erroneous
ideas a few years ago a fellow named
Arthur Miller wrote a play he called it
of all things Death of a Salesman
and they featured some dude named Willy
Loman the perennial loser and a lot of
people have come to identify that with
these sales professional and that is
absolutely weird wild insane way out
that they do sense they showed that
thing on a Broadway as a play they made
a movie out of it a long time ago and I
thought they'd finally put the deal to
bed and then they showed it on
television and then they showed it again
on television and then they revived the
play on Broadway and now they doing the
same thing again I could not believe why
don't they make a play entitled death of
a doctor our death of a lawyer
or something like that it makes even
more sense absolutely and then you take
the music man fella named Harold Hill
the consummate con man you know the
story behind it and a lot of people have
gotten these weird ideas therefore from
these presentations about what the
profession of selling really is all
about and then there's a fourth reason
and that's this old Yankee pedlar image
which is still a hangover yet an amazing
number of people think that any that a
good salesman can sell anybody anything
under any circumstances that's crazy
only a con man could do a thing like
that selling is not making people want
something they don't need nor is it
making them buy something they do not
want selling in the professional sense
is uncovering a need and then bring into
that individual the products are the
goods are the services which feel that
specific need now let me see if we can
establish some things here with some
questions how many of you folks sell a
pretty good product can I see your hands
okay how many of you sell an
extraordinarily good product can I see
your hand how many of you believe that
when you sell that good product well let
me ask you this way the products you
sell Hemet have you sell one that solves
a problem can I see your hand okay how
many of you believe that when you sell a
product that solves a problem but you
deserve a profit can I see your hand
okay how many of you believe then when
you sell two products that solve two
problems that you deserve to profits
gonna see your hands okay now what
you're saying is that the more problems
you solve the more profit you deserve
I'm not trying to put words in your
mouth because as the late Fred Herman
would say that ain't sanitary but that
really
you know that really is what you're
saying is that it okay now how many have
you been in the profession of southern
for as long as a year okay how many of
you still got all of the money you've
earned in the last 12 months okay how
many of you have got customers whom you
sold a year ago two years ago five years
ago ten years ago who are still using
and enjoying the benefits of what you
sold them a year or two years ago or
five years ago can I see your hands now
here's a very important question who
made the best deal was it you or the
customer the customer all right then is
the sales process something you do to
somebody or something you do for
somebody isn't it for somebody see I
fall in the ring two years matter of
fact the whole reason I quit was because
of my hands the referee kept stepping on
them one of the things one of the things
the coach used to always tell us when he
had send us out he said now Z the first
round spar around find out where the
opponent is weak and capitalize on the
weakness in football the coach says to
the quarterback
find out where they're weak and exploit
that weakness in tennis the instructions
are find out where the opponent is weak
and exploit the weakness in the world of
sellin we find out where the opponent
that is the customer is weak Vettius
has a need and strengthen that need by
selling them our goods products and our
services you see it really is true folks
selling is something you do for somebody
and not to somebody and that's our role
that's what we want to simply bring to
you what is the truth about what this
profession really is all about because a
lot of times people say okay Zig you got
me sold that the selling profession is a
marvelous profession now tell me the
truth about the
salespeople and tell me what the
salesperson receives as a result of
doing all of this selling and all of
this serving basically in my judgment
the salesperson is the ultimate free
person you're in business for yourself
but not by yourself you see the truth of
the matter is you're the chairman of the
board you're the president's you're the
secretary treasurer you're the chief
executive officer you're the
administrator and oh yes you're the
janitor - I mean salespeople we do the
whole bit don't we but the nice thing
about is you can get up any more than
you want to because you occupy all of
those positions you can get right in
front of that mirror give that big old
grin you know like a fellow I saw the
other day the only guy they were seeing
who could eat a banana sideways I mean
that guy was bitten I mean he really was
well you can get in front of that mirror
and you know you can look yourself right
in the eye and say you're such a nice
guy
or you're such a nice girl you deserve a
raise and the board just met the vote
was unanimous
the raise will become effective just as
soon as you are I mean you see the nice
thing the nice thing about this
profession of selling is that we do have
that ultimate freedom now when we talk
about Ultimates also in my judgment it's
the ultimate security in the world of
selling is where you're going to find it
as you might recall in the last
recession you know the newspapers and
the television and the radio have
predicted 18 of the last two recessions
I mean they seem to be right on the
target as my good friend Don Hudson who
would say but you know when you when you
analyze what they really say when you
look at that last recession for example
there were some pilots and attendants
who lost their job there were some
executives some builders some
manufacturers who lost their job there
were secretaries and stenographers and
file clerks who lost their job there
were teachers in superintend
who lost their job there were a lot of
people who lost their jobs these were
honest sincere dedicated hard-working
intelligent committed people they lost
their jobs not because they were not
committed not because they were not
productive but they lost their jobs
because of the economy that we
experienced now challenge you name me
one honest sincere dedicated
hard-working productive sales person who
lost their job during the recession I'll
never forget I was doing a sales
training seminar in Atlanta Georgia and
these two young men came up to me and
they said you know we'd like to get our
money back on the seminar unless they're
what's the problem they said well we
just got fired from our job and we have
no need for sales training if we don't
have something to sell I said well let
me ask you guys a question do you like
to sell I said oh yeah we love to sell
well trained and they were good-looking
young men 25 26 27 years old sharply
dressed you know they said we just had a
personality conflict with the vows I
said well would you like to have another
job in the world of selling they said we
sure would I said you come on into the
meeting and I'll have you twenty-five
job offers before you leave out here
tonight is that a fair deal is that it's
a fair deal and then that night I asked
the question how many of you will ask
you how many of you folks here tonight
are in the world of selling and you're
recruiting or hiring salespeople can I
see your hand now let me ask you a
question how many of you have an opening
right now for an honest sincere
dedicated conscientious hard-working
productive salesperson can I say you're
in they literally had more job offers
than they could even remotely consider
for at least the next two weeks now why
is that simply because a salesperson has
the greatest security in the world
general General Douglas MacArthur said
that security is the ability to produce
and my friends if you've got that
ability to produce in the world of
selling I can absolutely guarantee you
you really
do have that security now you know when
we do have recessions we deal with them
in different ways for example in the
business community and the regular
business structure you know how they
deal with recessions and declines and
drops and business they get to eat all
of the people together and the predator
of the company you know gets on his best
sad look anywheres this sad suit you
know and he makes this little brave
speech about we've got some tough times
ahead but we're gonna tough it out I
mean we're gonna tighten our belt we're
gonna cut the lights off ready I'm sorry
we're gonna have to let a few people in
this department go and a few people in
this department ago and a few people in
the other department go and we're really
gonna have to be on this austerity
program but we are going to tough it out
and that's the way they deal with the
recession now when sales organizations
are confronted with that situation they
call another big meeting they get all of
the folks together and say now folks you
know we hear this talk about this
recession but we have figured out a way
to deal with it we are all just going to
have to work real hard to reduce our
sales and that's the way we will solve
the problem and that's the way they
generally handle it how do they get
everybody together to say hey you've
heard all this baloney about a recession
let me tell you our answer to that man
we're gonna put on a sales contest like
you have never heard of before in your
entire lifetime we got to put up prices
like you cannot believe we're gonna
involve here some motivational training
programs and some sales training program
and we're gonna have some incentives
here that'll absolutely boggles the
imagination and I'll tell you what's
going to happen we're gonna get out
there and we're gonna show them where a
recession is we know business is never
either good or bad out there
business is either good or bad right
here between your own two ears and if
you're thinking it's thinking your
business is gonna be in the same shape
we're just gonna give all of you a
little checkup from the neck up and
we're gonna go out there and we're gonna
knock them dead and we're gonna say all
say also don't ask a question during the
last recession whenever he was how many
of you actually sold more during the
recession than you'd sold before the
recession can I see your hand
in the world of selling an absolutely
incredible thing yes indeed
the salesperson really is an unusual
individual do we make money how many of
you read US News and World Report can I
see your hand about a little while ago
in one of the issues of US News they had
a fascinating article in there you know
what the article said it said that more
salespeople are millionaires than
doctors now I don't know how that gets
to you but I kind of say aha hey what
about that we make more money I had the
privilege just last week of addressing a
sales organization the average income
was over $70,000 a year or in that
neighborhood and that's one more really
nice neighborhood
yes you know I talk to sales people all
the time who their first year in the
business make twenty and thirty thousand
dollars I've seen them who make a
hundred thousand two hundred thousand as
a matter of fact years ago Charles
Schwab who really was the master
salesman and Diamond Jim Brady those
dude made a million dollars a year
selling over a hundred years ago an
amazing thing this profession of selling
yes there is a substantial about a
amount of income possibilities there but
you know what else the conchs report
revealed here about two years ago that
in the world of selling
we're the ones who supply by far the
biggest majority of the corporate
officers now many years ago it was the
salespeople and then they drifted into
the accountants and the attorneys and
they made the corporate officers out of
them but in the last five years and the
trend is now on a runaway path they are
realizing that what they really need
running the organization is the
optimistic positive thinking outlook of
the sales organization and the
salesperson running that organization
they need somebody so optimistic they go
after Moby Dick in a row
take the tartar sauce wither I mean
basically you know that's the kind of
individual that they are looking for yes
it's great to be a sales person now
hopefully I've exploded a lot of the
myths about the profession of selling
and what the salesperson himself or
herself really earns but the question
comes up
who is the best salesperson what type
individual our personality makes the
best salesperson for years and years the
general public has been led to believe
that it's the extroverted happy-go-lucky
back-slapping hail-fellow-well-met
joke-telling
a kind of an individual who makes the
best salesperson I'm glad you are seated
because this might shock some of you but
if we were to divide this audience right
here in the two groups one group are all
introverts and the other group are all
extroverts I Got News for you the
introverts will outsell the extroverts a
hundred times out of a hundred that's
right now that probably shocks you now
that doesn't mean that maybe the best
salesperson might not be an extrovert
they could well be but I'm talking about
over the long haul now why is that an
incident elimination to add the
introverts in many cases have acquired
some of the characteristics of the
extrovert I mean they've learned to be a
little more outgoing a little broader
smile a little more enthusiasm and a
little better handshake in this kind of
thing but I'm talking about the nature
of the individual why would the
introvert make the better salesperson
there are several reasons for it first
of all it is because the introvert is
far more likely to be better organized
and they're better students they study
the procedures and the techniques
they're not as likely to say oh by the
quote seat of their pants they will
follow the procedures which are their
number two they're more detail-oriented
and incidentally more people or
they're far more inclined to ask
questions to uncover the needs of the
prospect and find out what the prospect
needs instead of trying to roughshod run
over them and dominate them with
personality and tell them all about the
wonderful merits of their merchandise
without finding first of all if their
needs will be met by what they're
selling third thing about introverts is
realistically folks they're more
introverts than they are extroverts and
so they have more people to relate to as
far as the process of selling is
concerned so what can those who are
extroverts knew about it the same thing
that introverts can do you can acquire
the training the characteristics and the
habits of the introvert just as the
introvert needs to acquire some of our
characteristics and yes people can
definitely do that
there's probably gonna shock most of you
when I tell you this because all you've
seen me here is in front a group of
folks and I'm laugh-in and I'm talking
real loud and I'm bouncing up and down
and I exude a lot of energy and a lot of
confidence and a lot of enthusiasm so
when I tell you this is probably gonna
shock you but I - I'm an introvert very
much so now you might think I'm the
loudest introvert you've ever seen in
your life
but emphatically I am an introvert I
have simply acquired some of the
characteristics of the extrovert you see
you're not stuck with the way you are
one of the best exciting things I can
tell you is that you can change I can
tell that you're what you are and where
you are because of what's going into
your mind you can change what you are
and you can change where you are by
changing what goes into your mind and
the beautiful thing about the profession
of selling is you have an opportunity to
be with and around the optimistic the
positive thinkers the people who are
encouraging in building you up and
helping you to do more of the good
things of life when you start talking
about the salesperson and the kind of
individual involved in it I think one of
the most exciting report
I've ever read was put together by the
forum corporation out of Boston
Massachusetts they did a considerable
study on three hundred and forty-one
salespeople one hundred and seventy
three of these salespeople were the top
night producers I mean the super
productive salespeople 168 of them were
average sales people now all of them had
been selling at least five years so we
can eliminate the rookie factor they
came from eleven different companies
five different industries they sold
everything from petrochemical banking
life insurance real estate and one or
two other things but in this analysis
they discovered that from a pure sales
knowledge sales skill point of view of
that the 107 to 3 top salespeople in the
116 average salespeople all had almost
exactly the same sales skills each group
knew exactly how to get prospects each
knew how to get appointments each knew
how to demonstrate features and benefits
each knew how to handle objections each
knew how to close the sales but that was
a dramatic difference in the results
because there was one factor that the
super salespeople had and that one
factor that the other ones did not have
in his larger quantity was this word
called trust and my southern friends
listen real good as I often tell people
this is profound what they found is this
people don't buy based on what you tell
them they do not buy based on what you
show them they do buy based on what you
tell them and what you show them that
they believe pure and simple which they
believe now the question is who do they
believe it's an old fashioned answer
they believe the good guys and the good
gals those who are moral is sound who
have honesty and character and integrity
as the regular tools in their sales
arsenal you see the most important part
of the sales process is the sales person
very important I see that kind of shoots
the myth that a lot of people have about
the salesperson the career salesperson
understands a lot of things for example
we learned some things about human
nature that helps us deal with our wives
or our husbands or our children or our
neighbors or somebody like that
for example as salespeople on occasion
we do have folks who are a little rude
to us how many of you who have ever had
a prospect who was rude maybe even mean
a little ornery
would you believe downright nasty what
do you see one of the things not often
fortunately but it does happen
one of the things we as salespeople
learn and understand is this when
somebody is mean and ugly to us we learn
to understand it is not because they
want to hurt us but rather it is because
they themselves are hurting and you see
once we understand that then we can deal
not only with them more effectively but
also with our families and our friends
and those whom we love
I believe we aren't any reasonable doubt
that in America if every policeman if
every politician if every schoolteacher
if every civil service worker if every
individual on any kind of payroll
anywhere if they had to go to a real gun
ho sales meeting every Monday morning
before they started walking their beat
or delivering the mail or doing whatever
job they there I believe we would have
an infinitely better happier more
excited producing America how many of
you would agree with that
now of course ladies and gentlemen
everything is selling and everybody is a
sales person whether you're a dentist a
doctor a preacher a teacher a coach a
child
music matters doesn't make any
difference what it is that you do
everybody is a salesperson let me share
a couple of examples with you of what
I'm talking about when I was between the
11th and 12th grades during World War 2
I went to junior college so I could pick
up some extra classes so I can get in
the Naval Air Corps all right now I had
to pick up an extra course in history in
order to graduate and so I would be free
then the following my senior year to
take a lot of extra math and science
well I didn't want to take American
history what possible good is it going
to do me you know to learn something
that happened 100 years ago or 200 years
ago but I had to learn it so I was going
to go in there and I was at least going
to pass but don't think I'm going to try
to remember it I'll just transfer the
knowledge from the teacher to my mind to
the pad and then I'll get out of there
and they'll end it but the teacher threw
me a curve he was coached joby
harrisonhines junior college in Jackson
Mississippi and you're talking about a
Salesman folks he was a Salesman he
spent that entire first period selling
me on why I had to learn my history he
really put the story on me he also sold
me that as an individual if I had any
ability that permitted me to do more
than support my family that I had a
moral obligation to my fellow human
being and my community to donate some of
my services for the betterment of
mankind
I walked out of that classroom that day
history major on the subject I made
consistent A's in throughout the time
in college what I do today and all of
the activities outside of my actual
business was directly emphatically
influenced by that salesman a school
teacher coach Toby Harris everything is
selling I'll never forget when our
second daughter was born our first child
was three years old at the time and I've
been out on the road not long after our
baby Obama came home from the hospital
I've been out on the road and I got
stuck there was a snowstorm and I spent
the night in a Greyhound bus fortunately
on the side of the road when I got in
the next morning I was exhausted that
was about ten inches of snow on the
ground and I'd no sooner walked in and
just had my top coat and my gloves in my
head off when the redhead said to me
well honey we got to go to the store we
got we need some things so I reluctantly
put all the gear back on and my
three-year-old said daddy I want to go
and I said Oh Suzie I said the weather's
too bad it's too cold and wet and I
won't be gone long but she said daddy
I'll be so lonely I said Oh Suzie you
won't be lonely I said your mother's
here the mage hear you baby sister is
here I said you won't be lonely she
looked right at me she said but daddy
I'll be lonely for you I don't need to
tell you she went to the store with
you see the truth of the matter is the
truth of the matter is everything is
selling the third example at our church
we recently got a new music minister now
please understand that I've got the kind
of voice that prompted miss Miller to
write me a personal letter asking me not
even to bother to sing along with you no
I want you to understand my own children
asked that I not sing in church but last
Sunday was our first Sunday and this
Minister had the congregation so excited
he sold them so much on participating
now he knows his music too but he had us
so gung-ho that for the first time in my
life I actually enthusiastically got
involved in the singing process
everything ladies and gentlemen is
selling I mean everything is selling and
that's one of the reasons that I'm so
excited about it the question might come
up well what role does selling play in
the economy well I can tell you this
several years ago the Secretary of
Commerce of the United States said this
he said that what we need in America
today is 1 million more sales people
professional sales people if you ever
really stopped to figure what happens
when you make a sale
now when you make a sale let me ask you
how many of you writes your order on an
order form or an order blank can I see
your hands please okay now when you make
that sale do you understand do you
realize fully that the auto pads you
wrote it on didn't I start out as an
auto pad it started out as a tree and
you're the person who paid those people
who went out in the woods and cut that
tree down when you got out there and
made the sale and then a whole bunch of
people hold that to to the paper mill
and you're the person who paid those
people to haul that to the paper mill
when you got out there and made the sale
now in the paper mill you see there
hundreds of people manufacturing that
tree and a papery of the person who paid
this beaver manufactured that tree in a
paper when you got out there and made
the sale but it goes so much further
than that you see when you made a sale
you made a profit on that sale and if
you're lucky your man
you made a profit if you're real lucky
your company made a profit that's the
way you stay in business you know and so
you take part of your profits you go
down to the store and you buy a can of
beans and in essence the grocer man says
if you know buy my beans I got to get
some more he goes to the wholesaler and
said need more bean Hostetter said if
you know buy my beans I gotta get some
more he goes to the counter and said
need more beans counter said if you know
about my beans I gotta get some more he
goes to the farmer and said need more
beans farmer said you gonna buy my beans
I gotta get some more
I'm gonna do that I gotta raise them to
raise them we gotta have a new trader
because the one I got swarming out he
goes down my dealer said hey I got
Elliot tractor him and instead of you
know by my type I got to get another one
because these are all we've got he goes
to the factory and said hey gotta have
new tractors and the factor said if he
no buyer traders we got to manufacture
some more to do that we got to bring in
iron copper plastic steel aluminum lead
zinc sparkplug well we got to set up
factors all over the world and all of
that happened because one day you got
out there and made
and as what y'all to tell folks why am i
excited about the profession of selling
I'm excited about their profession of
selling ladies and gentlemen because as
I said earlier I believe it is the most
secure profession on the face of this
earth if my son were to come to me and
say dad I want to get into something
that is absolutely secure what would you
suggest as being the most secure thing
on this in our country without
hesitation I would say well son you
ought to get in the world of selling but
suppose my son were to say to me but
wait a minute dad don't most salespeople
work on a commission and I would say yes
some salespeople are just like everybody
else everybody works on a commission but
Dad I thought your secretary Oh for
example had a salary oh she does son
she's on a salary and as long as she's
productive she will continue to receive
the salary now when she's no longer
productive what's going to happen to the
salary that's right
it's going to go see I don't care
whether you're preggers of the company
or even the President of the United
States
if you don't do like you're supposed to
do they'll get you
what I'm talking about don't you now you
see the beautiful thing about the world
of selling I would say to my son is it's
one of the few professions that I know
of that is absolutely not prejudiced you
see that alder doesn't care whether
you're white or black or brown it
doesn't care whether you're female or
male
it doesn't care whether you're old or
young it doesn't care whether you're
educated or uneducated doesn't care
whether you're introvert or extrovert
when you come bring in the auditors in
ladies and gentlemen and they start
writing those checks it's based on your
performance not the color of your skin
not your sex not your religious beliefs
not anything else it is the most fair
profession that I have ever seen in my
life I love to sell now we've got or go
ahead I've still got
there's an awful lot there's an awful
lot of selling we still need to do for
example in our society today does you
realize that 42 percent of the time
spent on jobs is wasted that's right I
was talking about the torah' doll time
management and productivity expert
internationally respected at the
University of Minnesota I said dr. Dahl
and when we were chatting and it was a
length of discussion I said I read this
figure but I have difficulty believing
that that much time is wasted
he said well Zig when you count people
coming in late and leaving early
extended coffee breaks unusually long
phone conversation too many trips to the
restroom taking time out to smoke those
cigarettes of a gossip that goes on
around a lot of these places too long it
lies making uh writing those personal
letters and all he says actually 42% is
a conservative figure what we need to do
ladies and gentlemen is tell everybody
on doing their very best when we sell
that idea I'll absolutely guarantee you
the trade deficit will absolutely
disappear if the producers will produce
the merchandise guarantee our sales
people are absolutely going to get out
there and sell we really are
now you're talking about import it let
me tell you something when you start
analyzing the sales profession even as I
make this presentation around our
country there are certain organizations
with your own strike in various plants
and mills and institutions and so forth
well let me tell you to think about this
if you ever have any doubts about your
validity as a profession and what you do
as a person wants you to think about
them did you realize that if everybody
in America who sold anybody anything
under any circumstances where there was
a piece of pie a loaf of bread a can of
beans a gallon of gas a life insurance
policy a home some pills from the
drugstore a suit of clothes some hair
shampoo a necklace around
your neck or microphone around your neck
if everybody in America who sells
anybody anything where to go on strike
just for 24 hours that you realize we'd
be thrown in a recession ladies and
gentlemen that it would take us months
and months to recover from the damage to
our economy would be absolutely
incredible you see what I'm saying is
the profession of selling is such a
marvelous marvelous profession I'm so
proud to be a part of it and I hope that
the next time anybody says anything
remotely derogatory about this
profession of selling if they get a
little negative and say something about
those salespeople I hope you will smile
be very gentle and be very loving but
look him right in the eye and say let me
tell you something friend you enjoy the
incredibly high income that you do
whether you're the postman or the
postmaster whether you are the teacher
or the superintendent whether you are
the sailor in the Navy are the Admiral
in the Navy
whether you are a clerk in the
congressman's office are the Congress
where the Congress person regardless of
what it is that you do you enjoy the
highest standard of living that you do
because sales people like me are out
there selling be proud you sell ladies
and gentlemen by these ideas we've been
talking about sometimes have change the
learners shot in here theories while
they learn and find themselves
beautifully equipped to deal with a
world that no longer exists for over
thirty years I've read an average of
three hours a day read my Bible every
day read the paper every day that will
be know what both sides are up to and I
just happen to believe that is very very
important when you start looking at all
of these things when you become a
constant student that's when you your
growth is more substantial and your
motivation and your inspiration and your
knowledge and here's been one of my most
interesting discovers and I've now
written a book on him it won't be out
for quite a little while yet but how to
develop a creative imagination the more
you know about anything the more
creative you become when you add
additional information to that when I
wrote secrets of closing the sale which
is the first book and only booked as a
manual on how the processes that you
follow in sales only have booked in New
York Times first time in that category
that ever reached the bestseller stayed
now what happened was very important
when I read that book when I had 98% of
it written somebody sent me a little
three short three paragraph summation
and what this little three paragraph
said was this is the heart of a sale it
was three short paragraphs I read those
three paragraphs and I added 50 pages to
the book I'd been selling since I was 8
been sales training since I was 21 I
knew a lot about sales the new
information revolutionized a whole lot
of things keep on going it helps a whole
lot of people when you talk about
relationships
Harvard Business class in 1949 almost a
little over 49% of all of the graduates
study was done on them in this class of
1949 49 percent of them were at least
vice presidents in major corporations
when asked how do they accounted for
that and CNN did a telecast on these men
he said well number one our wives were
supportive their careers were built on
integrity they were risk takers but they
did not where they were not gamblers
what do we do in our company how many of
the things that we teach and what do I
teach that are so important to me as I'm
talking about it now our mission
statement includes a big frying pan to
be the difference maker and the personal
family professional and spiritual lives
of enough people to make a positive
difference
in the world that's a pretty audacious
mission statement ladies and gentlemen
but it's got to be built on character
are we being successful in that well
over 40 languages of what I've been
teaching have been represented printed
and used we've got several several ends
from information bits that really really
have made a difference in the lives of
other people
in short with 40 translations of our
work in different languages we're
reaching an awful lot of people and we
teach things that are generally not
taught in school is I already have said
but I want to talk about another little
factor 90% of the visits to medical
doctors are directly or indirectly
related to stress 90% if we can reduce
stress and incidentally the same process
that reduces stress is exactly the same
process that will enable you to have a
long-term balanced career my stress
level and I face as many deadlines as
anybody you know it's always a book
production a class I'm teaching a
seminar I'm presenting and each one of
them requires time and concentration
example how many of you feel like I've
made this talk before can I see your
hand please
several hundred times I made it
yesterday you know what I did between
yesterday and today I spent over six
hours getting ready for today you see I
think it would be arrogant if I thought
I could stand up and spit it out just
because I did it yesterday are hundreds
of times that's arrogance that's when
Buster Douglas knocks out Mike Tyson
that's when an expansion team in Houston
beats an established NFL team in Dallas
I dare not look at the people here
several thousand I'm taking over an hour
that several panels and hours of time
where would my integrity be if I came
here unprepared to make something a
presentation that could make a do
it's in your life there is no way you
gotta prepare for it ladies and
gentlemen
when stress does hit you how many of you
will admit that after 9/11 maybe you had
a little stress can I see your hands
please all right let me tell you
something folks if you take their words
stressed and spell it backwards its
desserts when you respond to life
instead of react to it react is negative
you get sick go to the doctor so it
gives you a prescription so Sigma
tomorrow you walk in the next day she
said oh it's not working we got have to
change their prescription you get little
nervous but if she smiled and said hey
it's waking and so you have just he's
just responded and you feel better
because now you see some real hope in
order to get ahead in life you got a
couple of good friends through many many
years ago we're riding around in the
South Alabama foothills it was a hot
August day and they got thirsty
Bernard Haygood was driving Jimmy Glynn
was a passenger
they pulled behind this whole abandoned
farmhouse and Bernard hopped out he ran
over and there was an old pup on the
well and he grabbed a handle and he
started to pump how many of ever use one
of these old-fashioned water pump can I
see your hand please okay well here
that's a pump in a way you know it after
about three or four minutes he said
Jimmy better get that old bucket over
there get some water out of the creek
we're gonna have to prime the pump I
mean if you know what I'm talking about
when I say you got a prime the pump well
for you underprivileged non poppers that
just means you got to put something in
here before you get something out there
so enforcing a lot of people stand in
front of the stove of life and they say
now stove you give me some heat and I'll
put some wood in you that ain't the way
it works you got to put something in
before you can get anything out so many
times you know the employee goes to the
employer and said give me a raise then
I'll start coming to work on time all
right
so many times they will come to Evans
they make me the boss now I know I
haven't been here very long don't really
deserve to be the boss but I just
function better when I am in charge of
things you reward me now and then I
promise you I'll learn what this
business is all about
later on reward me now and I'll produce
later doesn't work that way
can't you just see a youngster in school
saying teacher if I take a failing grade
home my parents gonna skin me alive
paste me on this quarter and next time
I'll study more than anybody else reward
me now I'll produce later it doesn't
work that way can't you just see an old
farmer standing out in the fields in
October and said Lord I know I didn't
plant a thing this year but if you give
me a big crop this year I'll plant more
than anybody next year it ain't that way
folks you gotta put something in before
you can expect to get anything out well
he does a pump in a way you know that's
hard it's August I mean the question is
just how much pumping are you gonna do
Parker I drink the water and finally Oh
Bernard said you know what Jimmy I don't
believe it sending water down there
Jimmy said yeah it is Bernard you know
in South Alabama the wells are deepened
oh we're glad they're deep because the
deeper the well the cool of the cleaner
the sweeter the pure the better tasting
the water and isn't that true of life
into that if you could become an MD by
six weeks of summer school that the
rewards would be almost minimal or
nothing and how many patients would you
have ended to that if you become a sales
expert in three days of a training
school or that the rate of pay would go
down rather radically isn't it true that
anything worth doing is worth doing
poorly until you can learn to do it well
we'll never know how many kids have
missed a college scholarship because
they didn't study an average of ten more
minutes a day we will never know how we
come so close to promotion but we're
good discouraged and quit too soon we'll
never know how much more success we
would have had had we just had a little
more pumping in there and pump and pump
and pump and pump well finally Oh
Bernard just got disgust teeth rubbers
and you said Jimmy they're just no water
down there Jimmy said don't stop Barnard
don't stop if you stop they water's
gonna go all the way back down and then
you're gonna have to start all
all over the reality is folks and I'm
totally convinced of this this is the
story of America this is your story this
is a story of success this is the story
of life I believe with all of my heart
that if you would pump long enough and
hard enough and enthusiastically enough
that eventually the reward is going to
follow the effort and then once that
water starts to flow oh you got to do is
just people to be easy steady pressure
on it and you're going to get more water
than you can possibly use so many times
people get involved in something and
they'll say well I'll give it a try and
if it works out that'll be good and they
did if it doesn't work out I mean hang
on kill the track you know what I mean
by the way well I gotta tell you
something folks you're gonna pump
forever like that before anything
happens when you get into something grab
that sucker and dig with it and then
once the water starts to flow then
ladies and gentlemen that's what
strategies for success is all about
basic situation is this right now you
feel good there is no way you could feel
anything but good but what we want to
look at is what can we do to make
certain we feel good next week next
month makes you in other words how can
we keep it going how can we be up most
of the time and own when we need to now
I'm going to put a lot of emphasis of in
this session along the lines of the fact
that you can have everything in life you
want if you will just help enough other
people get what they want and what we're
going to do ladies and gentlemen is
we're going to work with a formula we're
going to give you some steps and
procedures which absolutely will make a
permanent difference in your life I
would like to remind you that we touched
on the first step in our last session
when I said to you the first thing you
want to do is you want to claim these
qualities of life you want to simply
adopt them as being yours you want to do
everything
you can on a steady basis to develop
those qualities further and further and
further step number two if you want to
be up most of the time and on when you
need to be if you want to build that
winning attitude then you need to be a
good finder I'm going to straight from
what a lot of people believe is the norm
in life the old look out for me first
and then if there's anything left you
can have it approach to life as I
indicated earlier we teach a seminar in
Dallas called born to win people do come
from everywhere
couple of years ago we had a major
corporation to send in for couples now
we encourage people to come with their
mates if they are married but it is not
a marriage seminar though we've seen a
lot of husbands and wives walk in at
each other's throats and walk out in
each other's arms because we did fit
them with those new glasses because we
did teach them how to communicate again
a lot of people really do think that
when they take turns talking that's
communication and that really is not
well in this three days I lectured twice
a day but most of the time is spin
around a round table with six other
people there's a lot of individual
instruction there's a great deal of
individual participation somebody has
rightly said that if you hear it you
forget it if you see it you remember it
but if you see it and hear it and do it
you understand and then you're
successful that's the reason we like to
get you involved it's the doing that
makes the difference again you got to be
before you can do you got to do before
you can have well these four couples
came to our born to win seminar and
we had them really involved when we have
these people around those round tables
every time anybody says anything or does
anything the other six people write them
a little note and it says I like James
Jones because and then they give some
specific observable behavior because he
is so pleasant and gives me
encouragement at work you could say
something like I like Bill Smith because
he brings his projects in on time and
under budget
but of the seminar at the end of it each
person there has got between 50 and
sometimes as many as a hundred and fifty
of those little slips and they they
literally keep them for months sometimes
even years well the first night these
four couples went out to a late dinner
at one of Alice's finest and certainly
one of our most expensive restaurants
they hit the jackpot with a waiter I
mean he was absolutely magnificent he
had been there over 20 years been a
waiter over 25 years
he was totally professional in every
aspect of his job he was there when he
was needed but he did not join the party
when there was a need he filled it and
disappeared and he could anticipate
those needs he really it was braved when
then they got his name and when they got
ready to leave they left him a 25% tip
which is significant I hasten to add
they also left each one of them did that
is one of those little I like because
slips they walked out the front door
they've gotten about a hundred feet
hundred and fifty feet from the front
door when they heard the waiters voice
from the rear he was calling them wait a
minute folks wait a minute they looked
and there he was
does he ran to them he is waving those
eight slips of paper he drew of rest and
he stopped he said you know folks I've
been a waiter over 25 years then they
said that he broke down and literally
could not say a thing for
it seemed like forever when he finally
regained his composure he said in 25
years this is by far the most
significant thing that has ever happened
to me he said I will never forget
tonight and with that he turned and
walked back in the restaurant never a
word about the tip just about those
little eight slips of paper my good
friend Cabot Robert from Phoenix Arizona
says there over three billion people on
the face of this earth to go to bed
hungry every night but he says there are
over four billion people on the face of
this earth who go to bed hungry every
night for a word of praise and
appreciation of love of hope of
affection of a courage encouragement
wouldn't it be tragic if one of those
people was your wife or your husband
that or your mom or your dad your son or
your daughter or for that matter someone
with whom you work every day of your
life
a nice person a nice lady a nice guy who
on the surface seems to have everything
going their way but deep down they're in
turmoil and a word of encouragement of
consideration of kindness of affected
you what a dramatic difference it could
make in their lives and it would only
take a moment
yes words of encouragement can make such
a dramatic difference in someone's life
three years ago I spoke down in
Melbourne Australia during one of the
breaks of a lady came up to me and and
she said mr. Zager I'm 32 years old she
said I have two little girls they're six
years old in there
years old they've had psychological
problems like you absolutely cannot
believe including a reversion to
infantile behavior she said I got your
tapes on raising those positive kids and
she said in one of them you say tell
your kids that you love them but she
said mr. Ziegler my 32 years of life
there's never been a living breathing
human being who said to me I love you in
your tape you just kept saying tell your
kids that you love them as she said as a
matter of fact it was weird because it
seemed every time I would put that
particular tape in it was always on that
exact spot if you don't tell your kids
that you love them they gonna grow up
and get married and have kids and they
will tell their kids that they love them
and somebody's got to break the chain
she said one night we were seated in our
den I was on one side of the room my
six-year-old was literally at my feet my
nine-year-old was across the room and
all of a sudden she said I remembered
and she said I just more or less blurted
it out the girls I just want you to know
I sure do love you she said had my
six-year-old been on a spring she could
not have gotten up any faster she was
like a shot out of a gun she threw her
arms around me and hugged me and kissed
me and started crying my nine-year-old
across the way ran across in see-through
our arms around him and she hugged man
she kissed me and she started crying and
of course by then I was crying too she
said mr. Ziegler I have no idea how long
we cried might just have been a moment
or two but it might have been five even
ten minutes she said all I know is that
when we finished crying that those tears
had washed away a lot of the hurt and
the pain and the bitterness even that
had crept into our lives though I was
emotionally exhausted there was a an
exhilaration that is impossible to
describe a feeling that I'd never had
before in my life
she said the girls and I promised each
other that night that never again would
we let a day go by that we didn't start
that day and in that day by hugging and
kissing and declaring our love she said
you know mr. Ziegler you would have
thought none of the emotions of the
moment the circumstances that were there
you would have thought that it would
have been easy and natural but you know
when we got away from the emotion of
that moment we started thinking about it
I felt awkward the next morning she said
I'm just so grateful that I was mature
enough to understand that if you always
wait until you feel like doing things
you will never really get them done and
so she said though it was awkward at
first because you cannot make an
overdraft on the bank of love all of
your life and then bring that account up
to date in one deposit I don't care how
big the deposit is but the next morning
awkwardly I grabbed my little girls
again I hugged him and kissed him told
him how much I loved him and they told
me the same thing took us a couple of
weeks before it even approached being
natural at the end of the month though
we were adding an occasional hug and
kiss extra and mr. Ziegler within sixty
days we just used any excuse for the
hugging and kissing and mr. Ziegler
within 90 days ninety-eight percent of
all of those psychological problems had
disappeared 2,000 years ago
Jewish scholar wrote a love letter to
his relatives in Corinth some say it's
the most beautiful love letter ever
written
he kind of summed it up by saying love
never failure I was interested to note
that when you chose those qualities of
success you put loving in there because
it is so important I take you back to
the story of the waiter now I got a
couple of points I want to make with
that story but what I'm just kind of
cute at least I think it's cute what
wouldn't you wouldn't you have just
loved to have been at the next table
that waiter served man don't you know
they got service like nobody has ever
gotten before and their life but the
real reason I tell the story the major
point I want to make is a very heart of
everything we do and that simply is this
philosophy that you can have everything
in life you want if you will just help
enough other people get what they want
why the next morning when those eight
people came in and remember now the
waiter said it was the most meaningful
event of his entire career but you
should have seen those eight people the
next morning they were so high we had to
pull him down off the ceiling before we
could bring them into the room they
bought a case of those little I liked
because back because they want to give
them to everybody it really does work
and you know I can almost I'm not a
mind-reader but I know where some of
your thinking is you might sit there and
say was they I can see where it would
work for that lady in Melbourne
Australia those were kids I can see
where it would work with that later
because after all the reality is he got
a bigger tip because he did such a job
who think you got to understand man
I work on Main Street I deal with Wall
Street this outfit I work with man their
bottom line can you use this philosophy
in the cold blooded hard-headed business
world in which we live my friend it
works better there than anywhere else in
the December 1987 issue of executive
excellence a publication of 16 pages
which has a lot of very concise and
pertinent articles in it there was an
article in it by dr. Ken Blanchard and
dr. Blanchard was or is the man of one
minute manager Feynman and dr. Blanchard
reported on a study which had been done
concerning investing in the Dow Jones
and here's what he said had you put
thirty thousand dollars 30 years ago in
the Dow Jones right across the board the
composite he said today you would have
in excess of $100,000 but he said had
you taken the same $30,000 and
ambassador in the 21 companies which
have ethics as the base from which they
operate these qualities right here
ethics the base from which they operate
plus they have an announced public
policy that the reason they're in
business is to serve the public you can
have everything in life you want
you'll just help enough other people get
what they want today you'd have over
$1,000,000 same article same article he
reports on a study done by Arizona State
University of the companies which have
paid dividends for the last 100 years
now folks that's financial stability if
there's ever been financial stability
and these companies have ethics as the
base from which they operate and
and announced public policy but the
reason they are in business is to serve
the public it's absolutely true you have
everything in life you want if you'll
just help enough other people get what
they want so step number two if you
really want to keep that attitude right
if you really want to build that career
and if you really want to do the things
in life that will make you successful
become a good finder now incidentally
folks you know again I'm not a
mind-reader but I know sometimes when
people sit there and seminar you get to
thinking well I don't know if I won't do
all that like this idea of standing in
front of the mirror and claiming all of
those qualities I'd be a little
self-conscious Ziglar if I do that now
I'll look at him from time to time but
to go through that rigmarole you talk
about I don't know about that Fred let
me ask you a question what have you got
to lose
nobody's even gonna know about it but
you but suppose it does what I'm telling
you
will do wouldn't it be tragic if you
chose not to take a simple suggestion
that would make a dramatic change in
your life claim the qualities number one
number two become a good finder number
three you need to get an education one
of the things that I do in our company
when we bring someone new aboard at the
moment we have about 80 people and when
we bring someone aboard I like to spend
a little time talking with them to let
them know what they can expect from us
and kind of find out what we can expect
from them kind of to get to know that
individual recently we had a beautiful
lady to join us after stead been
on vacation for 23 years now those of
you who are mothers will say Ziggler
thought what no vacation seriously she
had raised her children
now she was rear end that we enter in
the workplace and see what starting back
and you can understand why she would be
a little apprehensive and incidentally I
understand raising kids it's not a
vacation and I would never even bother
imply that but now she's shifting gears
and as she came in the first question
she asked me was do you discriminate
because of a lack of education and I
said well we certainly do she looked a
little stunned and obviously
disappointed but I said we never
discriminate because of a lack of
schooling now there's a dramatic
difference in the two you say you can
finish school and I definitely think you
should you can even make it easy and I
definitely think you should not but you
can never finish your education and it
is never easy it's something that goes
on and on and on I'm absolutely
convinced that there's literally no
excuse in America today for anybody not
to have a brilliant education if you can
even read at the 5th grade level and if
you cannot read at the 5th grade level
go to your Public Library we can put you
in touch with the people who are
teaching illiterate have to read in most
every case once you've gotten turned on
to what it can mean to you I believe you
will do it there's no excuse for not
being brilliantly educated all you need
to do is three very simple things number
one you should learn one new word every
day now ladies and gentlemen that's not
an earth-shattering task Reader's Digest
has an article every month or a page in
there it pays to enrich you a word power
one new wear today in five years you can
talk to just about anybody about just
about anything not because you know a
whole lot of big words but because they
have broadened your base it's gone
broader and deeper you see every time
you learn a new word that words got a
couple of bloodiest and those buddies
have got buddies you learn one you are
today and in five years I'll absolutely
guarantee you it will make a difference
one study involving thirteen hundred and
sixty-one executives revealed and these
are top level executives real a revealed
that they had outstanding vocabularies
Vince Roberts lives in Ottawa Canada now
Vince was 37 years old he had a fifth
grade education he was a cab driver and
he literally spent hours every week at
the airport waiting on a fare he spent
hours every week at the hotels waiting
on a fare and then one day something
happened and Vince Roberts is life I do
not know what it was but something
happened he became inspired he realizes
that he did not have to stay like he was
our query was so a bought himself a book
the book he bought was a dictionary a
twenty-pound
dictionary and starting on page one wait
for word for a word he went all the way
through that twenty pound dictionary
twice he end up on in the cab company he
ended up investing in the stock market
becoming a very wealthy man today he
travels telling people how you did it
how he did it now my friend there is no
excuse on earth there's no reason why
you cannot learn at least one new word
and it absolutely will make a difference
step number two in order to get that
education you need to read at least 20
minutes every day now I spend about two
hours a day or more but you got to
understand this is my business this is
my life this is my profession I got to
do it fortunately I just absolutely love
to do it but 20 minutes a day will make
a dramatic difference now obviously I'm
talking about reading something good
powerful positive biographies
autobiographies self-help books
motivational books books about your
business your profession the industry of
which you are a part looks about human
nature how to deal with people if you
are an average reader that's 220 words a
minute if you will just read 20 minutes
a day at the end of the year you will
have read 20 200 page books that is 18
more than the average American reads in
a year's time that will give you a
colossal advantage in whatever it is
that you're doing folks the reality is
just a little advantage is all most of
us need it's the little things that make
the big difference in life you call it
girlie kittens you'll absolutely love
you call her a cat you got a problem
friend a bad problem if you say she's a
vision you score all kind of points call
her a sight you're in trouble
fellas can you imagine you look in your
wife's eyes and say honey when I look
into your eyes the wheels of time just
stand still oh that's beautiful that's
poetry but can you imagine what will
happen if you look at knives and say you
know honey
when I look into your eyes the weed
there when I look into your eyes I just
am reminded that you got to face it stop
a clock I mean ladies and gentlemen
that is something that would make it
it's the little things that make a big
difference if my watch is for hours
wrong no problem
but if it's four minutes wrong I'm in
trouble because you see I'm scheduled to
leave this afternoon at 3:45 if it's
four minutes slow and I get there at
3:49 well you can see the problem
because I made a deal with the airlines
that if I'm not there when they get
ready to go that they're just to go
ahead without me
and as far as I know they've always
lived up to their end of the agreement
they did it last year in Dallas I can
say that little things make a big
difference in life the third thing you
need to do to get that brilliant
education is you need to regularly
listen to cassettes when you're in your
automobile for example the average
salesman according to my friend Don
Hudson spends 510 hours a year in his
automobile while you're in that car and
the average person incidentally I was a
visiting scholar at the University of
Southern California for two years and
they did a study which revealed that if
you live in a metropolitan area and
drive twelve thousand miles a year that
in three years time you can acquire the
equivalent of two years of college
education while you're in your
automobile you can literally learn
everything from Chinese art and a
foreign language to the Bible to
financial planning to gold setting to
how to close a sale to how to
communicate more effectively there are
hundreds of things that you can learn in
your automobile it ought to be the
greatest educational institution
literally in the world you spend ten
thousand 15 20 30 even 40 thousand
dollars on a car and yet the typical
American let me tell you what if they do
they stomp their foot and gripe and
groan and complain every time the
traffic gets a little heavier they see a
gem up front and they say dag gone it
all when are they gonna do something
about this when the order when they see
a traffic jam and saying oh boy I bet
it's gonna take me 30 minutes to get
through that sucker and
two minutes I can learn three new words
I can learn two new closes I can learn
about financial planning that's what I'm
talking about using the time that you
have you gotta go anyhow I not get an
education while you're on the way and
that won't take one minute of your time
incidentally folks when you talk about
time let me remind you that 72 percent
of the time when we're watching
television we're watching something we
have no interest in we rush home to see
a particular cell The Cosby Show
wonderful show I've already seen it
twice it is a good show but a lot of
times people will mash the button and
change of talent what's on the other one
and four hours later they say well I
can't believe I've spent the whole night
here doing nothing I'm talking about
utilizing your time so step number three
is get an education step number four if
you really want to go to the top you
want to maintain that attitude you need
to learn how to say hello you need to
know how to greet people properly
whether it's in person or whether it's
in the phone on the phone now I do
something and I've been doing it a long
time regardless of what time of day it
is when I greet people I always say good
morning
and whether it's nine o'clock in the
morning or nine o'clock at night they
always respond in 85 percent of the
cases that is they'll say good morning
now a lot of times it'll after they said
ago so it's not morning and I'm so why
did you say good morning man I said I
said it cause you said it I said that's
right that brings out something very
important ladies and gentlemen that's
this when you go out in life to find
friends they're very scarce when you go
out to be a friend they're everywhere
what you send out it is what you get
back if you complain because people in a
certain area are building we're not very
friendly can you honestly say that you
initiated Inlet friendliness yourself
send it out and you will get it
greet people enthusiastically whether
it's in person are on the telephone now
I challenge you to do this when the
seminar is over go get two yellow pages
out look up ten numbers swap with one of
your buddies who's got ten numbers and
those ten numbers in our guarantee you
no more than three out of the ten again
can you identify what the name of that
business is you really cannot snatch the
phone off the hook because if it weren't
intrusion what do you mean dollars
number I wouldn't bother you good
monitor company and you have no more
idea banned a goat who you have called I
challenge you call us in Dallas 214 233
91 91 got a watch number but do you more
good spend your own dollar call us down
there and our lady will pick up that
telephone and with considerable
enthusiasm she'll say good morning now a
lot of people say thank was it always a
good morning it sure is and if you don't
believe it you just try missing one of
them then she makes a little
motivational speech he says it's a great
day at Zig Ziglar mine this is surely it
may I help you there 11 words involved
it takes four to five seconds to do that
it will save you an average of nine
seconds because nobody ever says how'd
you say it well switch companies is
where are you they've gotten the
communication very clearly now when I'm
at home and I do stress this is when I'm
at home when I answer the telephone I
answer it many times singing it or good
morning to you now be the first admit
sometimes there's a long pause
a lot of times I was saying if you don't
speak about they're gonna hang up and
they'll say lose it whoever you want who
do you want man you sure do fielder good
today
I said yeah many years ago I decided I
was going to feel good today good friend
of mine before his tragic death dr. John
Kasich a brilliant young psychiatrist
told me that over 90% of the way we feel
is determined by the decision we make as
to how we want to feel and how we expect
to feel there 51 diseases which are
psychosomatic in origin answer with
enthusiasm a lot of times I'll pick up
the phone I'll there say Heidi Heidi
Heidi now my favorite way of answering
the phone at home good morning this is
James Ziggler happy husband
I'll do it for two reason number one is
the truth and number two fellas you just
can't believe how many points I score
with that Rhydian when I answer that
telephone that way and I love to score
points with idiot now when one of my
grandchildren turn around I have two
little right age for this one of them is
named sunshine for obvious reasons the
other one is named keeper now you know
when a fisherman pulls in a good and
he's got a keeper and so when we first
saw her we knew we had a keeper and
that's where the name comes from if one
of them are around I'll pick up the
telephone and I'll say good morning this
is Sunshine's Prag granddaddy those
little eyes just light up and think of
what that does to her self-image one day
keeper was over at the house she and I
had been talking up in my office the
redhead was down in the den and I've
been keep her laugh man went downstairs
and I had to ask the redhead some so I
just picked up the phone and dialed her
and keep her picked up the telephone she
said good morning this is mammals
happy-happy granddaughter i'll tell you
ladies and gentlemen these kids really
really get with the program they follow
the Bible which is that and you might
say well Zig now why do you do this well
let me tell you something folks I do it
because again you cannot separate your
personal life from your family life and
from your business life we were very
fortunate early on we discovered that
kids go where there's excitement they
stay where there is love there has never
been a generation in our nation's
history that is as starved for affection
and intimacy as is this current
generation and they are not getting it
and that is one of the reasons they turn
to drugs and promiscuity the reason they
get involved in gangs and some of the
vandalism that take place we discovered
that if their love was there and the
excitement was there
other kids would come play in our den
and living room our children's friends
wanted out of curiosity what kind of
people are they up there that answer the
telephone that way so they would come up
sometimes we had a traffic jam but I
would prefer fourteen of those kids in
our den and us know everything going on
then they have my child somewhere else
and they have no idea of what was
happening now I kind of hit the jackpot
again in this the redhead is officially
known as the happy hugger if it's moving
she will stop it and hug it and if it is
not moving she'll dust it off and sell
it so when these kids when these kids
would come in the red head would
government give them that hug in many
cases that was the only hug they'd
gotten since the last time they had been
there it creates an amazing environment
by answering the phone that way parents
I challenge you to do this if the
telephone rings and your daughter is
standing or sitting around mom just pick
up that telephone and with a big grin on
your face and a lot of enthusiasm say
good morning this is Molly's proud mom
that if you're there and the phone rings
you pick up that telephone and you say
good morning this is Paul's proud pop
and you might have that old go key go
click gangly a 15 year old boy standing
there and he might say Oh dad but I'll
guarantee you the next time the phone
rings he will wait for you
it is the ultimate compliment when one
of my grandchildren over there they
never answer the telephone they go to
the telephone but they wait for me to
answer that telephone I can tell you do
wonders for their self-image dad let me
talk to you just for a moment dr. Oz
Campbell says this he says every little
six-year-old boy has only gotten 1/6
there's much hugging and kissing as the
average little six-year-old girl over
and in the first grade little boys
getting 9 times as much trouble
9 times as likely rather to have a
speech difficulty as our little girls
dr. Campbell said that in all of his
years of research and all of his years
of practice he has never known a single
human being with a sexual dysfunction
who had a father who was gentle and
affectionate and compassionate and
loving and kind and some of those other
feminine qualities there's still a bunch
of those macho men who say golf kiss my
little boy and make our [ __ ] out of him
the absolute opposite is true
the kids are starved for skin they want
hugging they want to know that you care
fellas I'll say the same thing about
your wives let me tell you something
they resent it when you ignore them all
day and then give them your undivided
attention when the lights go out and as
a practical matter how there's flat tell
you if you gripe about the mashed
potatoes at supper or dinner all you're
gonna get the rest of the evening is
cold shoulder
your relationship I believe we are
hungry all over this land for people who
are willing to hug when hug is all
they're interested in step number four
learn to greet people in person if
somebody asks you how you doing
instead of the old negatives that you
often hear well fine since it's Friday
or good since I get off in 20 minutes
are great since it's pay day and it's
11:00 when there's some people is my
good friend Roy Hatton says when they
pull themselves up to their full height
and say well under the circumstances I
mean he makes you wonder what they're
doing under ban the first place does it
now the next time somebody asks you how
you do and why don't you just tell them
the truth why don't you say outstanding
but I'm improving or super good but I'll
get better if you might say busy suppose
I'm not doing super good am I telling
the truth of course you're telling the
truth you're just telling it in advance
that's all why wait only good stuff
claim and now enjoy it now step number 6
to build that winning attitude we need
to shape up ladies and gentlemen I'm
sorry you know what I just did I skip
step number five hey you don't want to
do that step number five cancel that one
as we just say down home some folks
could file up a two-car parade and so
let's back up to step number five for 27
hours a year you do something that's
kind of neat that we have to do you know
negative Americans amaze me and yet so
many of them are so negative they call
those electrical appliances on the
street corners red lights or stop lights
or traffic lights but they really are
put there to make traffic go so the
reality is they are go lies damn ask you
a question have you ever been at one
go lights and you got to spend 27 hours
a year incidentally waiting on the right
color and you're sitting there waiting
on the right color to come along you're
all excited you're all enthused you're
highly motivated you're listening to you
Zig Ziglar tapes and you look at the
side of your eye and you can't believe
what you see here sits a guy over here
and he is waiting on the right color to
come along but he's got a good firm grip
on that steering wheel I mean he doesn't
want that car to go anywhere got a mouth
fixed exactly right just in case he has
to talk to that thing and you can't
believe it you watched him he's got his
foot on the accelerator his racial
enzyme trying to change the color the
light let me ask you a question how many
of you've actually ever seen some NoDo
sit down racing the car motor trying to
change the color of the light can I see
your hand please folks I hate to be
negative matter of fact I won't be
negative I'll be that little boy came
home school one day and said dad I'm
afraid I flunked out rithmetic test as
dad said son that's negative be positive
he said dad I'm positive I flunked a
trip up there I'm absolutely positive by
racing that car motor you're not gonna
change the color of that light there was
no while and I know we got some very
prominent enormously successful people
watching this and some of them are very
sophisticated and I know some of them
say well I certainly would not say super
good but I'll get better or outstanding
but I'm in but I just wouldn't say
things like that
that's a little amateurs that's even a
little juvenile well friend if you think
it's juvenile to say super good but I'll
get better just what do you think it is
to sit there and race that car motor
trying to change the color of the light
now that's just not gonna work good
friend of mine Bernie logic in Winnipeg
Canada is really more a brother Bernie
is the most positive human being I've
ever seen heesu positive he's never had
a cold one centigrade while he has a
warm
he's a positive you want to even talk
about the weekend he says that's
negative because it's the strong and
and you might say not come on Zack Lee
you got to be kidding me
super good strong hands go lights all
that guy stuff is that necessary
now you can be mediocre without it
mediocre who does that dude think he's
talking to I'm the president of my own
company mediocre worth over ten million
dollars mediocre why I have led the
nation in sales every year for the last
three years
mediocre I've got to pH sneeze well
bullet for you
I still say mediocre because success is
not measured by what you've done
compared to what somebody else has done
you might have 10 times the ability we
have success real success is measured by
what you've done with the ability you
have compared to what you could have
done with the ability you have this
procedure is not designed to help you
beat anybody this is designed to make
you number one you see everybody can't
be the biggest in the fastest and the
strongest and the smartest but everybody
can be number one and you are number one
when you get up every morning and look
yourself in the mirror and say today I'm
gonna give it my best shot you're number
one when at the end of that day you can
get back in front of that mirror and say
today I gave it my best shot you're
number one with the one who is the most
important as far as your success is
concerned so step number five if
somebody asks you ladies and gentlemen
directions instead of saying you go down
to the red light tell them the truth you
say you go down to the go light and the
minute you say go light you're granted
like you walk through a swinging door on
somebody else's push I mean you'll get
sad about it because it will remind you
of today it will bring you right back in
your own mind right here and your whole
pattern of thinking will be lifted step
number six shape up physically now when
I talk about shaping up physically
they're about three factors involved
remember we deal with a physical we deal
with a mental we deal with a spiritual
the first thing in shaping up physically
is you need to get enough sleep the
evidence is overwhelming that when you
sleep that's the only time certain
chemicals are reproduced in your brain
and these chemicals are necessary to
keep your body in balance you know if
you do not get enough sleep the first
thing you lose is that incredible energy
the second thing you lose is you lose of
that alertness that makes a difference
and third you become more susceptible
susceptible to becoming addicted to
prescription drugs or the illegal drugs
so get enough sleep what is enough I
don't know but you do if you have to
fight your way awake every morning try
getting a little extra sleep if that
doesn't work see your doctor you might
need a physical then you need to get on
a proper diet and exercise program there
are many good books today that you
really need to look into if you're
really going to take care of your health
a lot of times as I've said earlier I am
a jogger many times people ask me when
do you have time to jog but the reality
is when you exercise whether it's a fast
walk or bouncing up and down and down on
rebound alright in stationary bicycles
or bicycles on the street or swimming
whatever you do you activate that
pituitary gland it pledged a system with
the endorphins your energy level goes up
your creativity goes up I run five days
a week and I find my energy level is
always higher for the next two to five
I don't spend time exercising I invest
time and get a tremendous return third
thing to do about your physical
conditioning folks is avoid the poisons
now there's some people who get a little
uncomfortable when I say this but I've
got to tell you what I know is truth
there's an old saying that you can deny
truth but you cannot avoid it
the day's gonna come when it will be
there every time you light up a
cigarette you have just decided to die
16 minutes earlier than you otherwise
would have died I'm talking about
something very serious folks three
hundred and ninety thousand people a
year die as a direct result of smoking a
hundred and fifty thousand died as a
direct result of drinking we do know
that every time you take a drink that it
killed certain brain cells and I don't
know how many brain cells you got
personally I don't have a single one to
spare I encourage you do the things that
will make you the most functional I've
even had certain people to say well you
know I took a drink it sharpens me up
man gives me that little edge now me and
you know both no you don't really
believe that let me tell you why I know
we both don't believe it here's why if
you were faced with major surgery would
you insist that surgeon has a little
snort just before he opens you up no way
and you're not as sharp either if you
really want to build a winning attitude
step number seven you need to give it
your best shot
whatever it is that you do give it your
best effort
now in corporate America ladies and
gentlemen I believe that the worker who
has said I will be there at eight
o'clock that's when my day to start and
I'll state a fact I believe most of them
will do exactly that but the question
here's how do they get there at eight
o'clock here's what I've noticed I've
notice that most of them get there
absolutely in a dead run I mean at least
200 yards they get there I mean they are
all huffing and puffing
the traffic was that I didn't think I
was gonna pay you know they're unpacking
their gear and they make their way back
to the culvert I get him a cup of coffee
and they come back and they finish on
the back in it and ten minutes after
their pay starts then they go to work
now they supposed to work until five
o'clock I believe the American worker is
a conscientious sincere individual and I
believe that if they're supposed to be
there at you know that particular time
and stay there until 8:00 till five
o'clock I believe a stay until five
o'clock but if you could turn the video
cameras on corporate America all over
America at five o'clock here's what
you'd see little workers run a
three-point stance the bell rings and
boom like they're shot out of a cannon
what they do then is they get out of
there now they talk about the freeways
being dangerous today let me tell you
where the danger is it's trying to get
out of corporate headquarters and out of
the parking lot
that's where the danger is let me tell
you something you want to get ahead and
what you're doing then my friend let me
encourage you get there ten minutes
early be ready to go at eight o'clock
that's so important
stay there until five o'clock and then
you pack up at five o'clock and then you
leave after choice rather says you
cannot consistently perform in a manner
which is inconsistent with a way that
you see yourself this will do so many
wonderful things for your image because
you know you are doing what you're being
paid to do you're accepting
responsibility you're a discipline
yourself to do the job properly and I'll
tell you something else the boss is
looking there and those first 10 minutes
of those lies to him and it's
definitely will make an impression give
it your best shot when I was a boy down
in Yazoo City Mississippi I was born in
LA that's lower Alabama but when I was
in Yazoo City Mississippi I worked in a
grocery store in those Depression years
we used to borrow merchandise from other
stores
Charlie Scott was the runner from across
the street and Charlie used to come
running in our store to borrow food from
us like if it store ran out of tomatoes
he'd come right over there to say mr.
Anderson who owned our store I need a
bar a half dozen Candida mater's but mr.
Annan would say okay Charlie you know
where they are go get them and old
Charlie would go off in a mad dash he'd
grab up the half-dozen Canada made it
he'd bring him back he'd plop him down
on that counter you know it's giving his
name on the receipt he would take off
like a scalded bug one day I said mr.
does not come Charlie Scott always runs
mr. Anderson kind of smile he said well
he always runs because Charlie's Scott
is working for a raise and he's gonna
get it too I said mr. Anderson how you
know Charlie Scott gonna get it raised
he said I know Charlie Scott's gonna get
a raise because of the man he's working
for it does it give it to him it's an
absolute fact of life that when you do
more than you're paid to do you will
eventually be paid more for what you do
I was speaking at Clarksville I was
speaking in coastal Mississippi at the
University of Mississippi State when I
finished that seminar a tall redheaded
gentleman came up to me and he said mr.
Zieg lady said one of you lysine
Charlie's God I said well oh well left
for the Navy back in 1944 Charlie is 2
years old and I mean he left two years
before then I haven't seen him since he
said you probably wouldn't even know him
would you and I said no I really would
he said I didn't think so he said I'm
Charlie Scott
his friends told me that Charlie Scott
had taken the lessons of childhood until
they became the instincts of his adult
life at age 50 he retired a very wealthy
man
I simply am saying this to say to you
ladies and gentlemen that it makes no
difference where you start that if you
will take these principles that we've
been talking out throughout this entire
seminar that they in fact will enable
you by utilizing the principles by
developing the qualities which we have
identified by applying yourself by
giving it your absolute best shot that
you can start from where you are and get
the things you want in life I will
remind you yet one more time that
failure is an event it is not a person I
will remind you that regardless of
what's happened in the past the future
can absolutely be magnificent I also
will encourage you to spend some of the
time of your life with the ones that you
love our research states beyond any
reasonable doubt that if we have balance
in our life we're going to be able to
accomplish more of our objectives than
if we only have that one financial
objective and again I'm not putting
money down but there are a lot of other
things that go along with it I close
with this believe in you you were
created by God in his own image he loves
you he wants the best for you believe in
your fellow human beings believe in what
you're doing give it your best shot
believe in the good old USA I've been
almost all over the world folks there's
not another land like it how lucky we
are to be here take advantage of its
opportunities and finally that I've been
on trial for my life and has you been my
judge and my jury and had you
commissioned me to tell you
things that you needed to do to get the
most out of your life with my very life
at stake I would have said to you
exactly what I have said so take these
steps follow these procedures because if
you do I'll see you and yes I really do
mean you at the top thank you and god
bless you thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know what did you think of this video
that it did something changing you did
you get inspired you get motivated I
hope so
leave it in the comments below let me
know what you think and let me know what
your favorite part about it was and what
change you're gonna now make in your
business or your life as a result of
watching this video because watching
alone isn't enough you got to take some
action finally I want to thank Jenny
chin thank you so much for buying a copy
of my book it really means a lot to me
those are you watching you want your
chance at a shout out in a future video
make sure to pick up a copy of the book
and email in your receipt so we can keep
track and send you the bonuses thank you
guys so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon